hey youtubers is charlie this week for
my arrow bonus video I wanted to talk
all about Malcolm Merlyn John Barrowman
has been talking about the character and
Andrew Kreisberg talks about him in a
new season 3 featurette i'll also be
counting down my top 5 Malcolm Merlyn
moments from seasons one and two and big
reminder flash is coming tuesday october
seventh arrow is coming wednesday
october eight i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes so be sure to subscribe
everything it's going to be a really fun
season especially with Gotham and
Constantine happening too so if you
haven't seen it Andrew Kreisberg who's
an executive producer on air on the
flash did this featurette where he talks
about the themes of season 3 you have to
preorder season 3 on itunes to get the
clip i can't upload it to youtube i saw
someone tried and they totally got the
banhammer he explains what the character
development is and with the bigger
themes of season three are from Oliver's
perspective season two was a my killer
in season three it's all going to be
about identity Who am I that's going to
trickle down to all the other characters
including Malcolm Merlyn Merlyn Anthea
find themselves in this really
interesting situation where one has lost
a child Tommy and one has lost her
mother Moira he had these two people
trying to figure out how to form a new
family unit with Merlin's past in the
League of Assassins casting this giant
shadow over everything they do that is
where the fun starts Oliver Merlyn have
both bottled up a lot of their demons
you know Oliver balled up Slade stuck
him down in the island and is also you
know following up a lot of emotions and
merlin has bottled up his past with the
League of Assassins Chris Berg tease
that there's always an opportunity for
those demons to get out you know get out
of their bottles I like the suggestion
that ratio cool head of the demon is
also Merlin's demon although he's kind
of going to be a demon for everyone he
is the big bad of the season and just a
reference late I know a lot of you are
wondering if he's going to come back you
know Chris Berg did say bottle demons
may be getting out that could mean slate
is getting out they haven't shot all the
episodes this season they've only shot
about half the season and they haven't
even written some of the final episodes
so there's still the opportunity I'm not
expecting him back though I think he was
also winking to komodo in that interview
who's actually going to be in episode 2
will meet him in episode 2 in the comics
Komodo is something of a bottle demon
from Oliver and is
others passed it's unclear whether or
not it's going to be an exact
translation from the comics but Komodo
is going to be a fun lesser villain what
I'm really looking forward to though is
the thing or the moment that brings team
Merlin and team arrow together I'm
obviously expecting that to be the
League of Assassins and racial cool but
it could totally be something else John
Barrowman basically been doing the
rounds you know doing his arrow
interview rounds he said that Malcolm
Merlyn is ultimately a person looking
for redemption even though he's probably
not going to find it this season he'll
be using a few different tactics this
season to find a measure of redemption
especially through Thea behrmann
explained that season one was more about
using power and just epic villainy to
get what he wanted this season is more
about a personal approach playing on
emotions ultimately though it's all part
of his path to Merlin's redemption John
Barrowman in real life explained that he
doesn't think that Merlin's ever gonna
find any redemption like it'll be like
the end of his life it's going to take
his entire life to find it so we might
not see it happen on the series but we
can look forward to though is some
really awkward Merlin family moments
with Thea if he's trying to play on her
emotions then he's kind of trying to
coddle up to her a little bit and train
her at the same time as we've seen in
the trailers it'll be really fun
balancing act but I'm looking forward to
the thing that throws him back into the
action in Starling city because
obviously he probably doesn't care about
Oliver now he's got Thea he's got what
he wants still something is gonna have
to throw him into Oliver's path but as
of the beginning of season 3 it's
unclear whether or not they're going to
be in Starling or if they're going to
show up in that first episode hopefully
they will it seems like during the break
they've been away training somewhere
else just based on the scenes in the
trailer generally we can just expect to
see a lot more Merlin in his domain so
I'm really looking forward to team
Merlin scenes but here are my top 5
Malcolm Merlyn moments from seasons one
and two starting with number five Merlin
tells Oliver the hood should change his
name to green arrow this was episode 9
from season 1 years and it was basically
at the mid-season finale Merlin had just
killed Adam hunt so the dark Archer was
rearing his head in Oliver was still
trying to deflect attention from the
vigilante it was before people were
calling him the arrow Merlin already
suspected Oliver was the vigilante so
they're all sitting at the dinner table
having this very Hannibal type meal for
watch Hannibal that's just a show where
they do crazy dinner scenes between the
villain and the hero later in the
episode of merlin totally kicked
Oliver's ass it was like one of their
first big big fights the whole thing
about the green arrow though is just a
big wink at the comics I love that they
gave the line to the big villain of the
year how great is that the villain can
presumably see into your future in a way
that you cannot it's just at the time
Oliver had no idea what team arrow is
gonna turn into and obviously he's just
now learning about the Justice League
stuff that's going on like he's just
starting to team up with other big
superheroes number four Merlin throws
down in a tuxedo in front of tommy this
was from season 1 episode 16 dead to
rights it was fun to just see Merlin get
his James Bond moment in the tuxedo even
crazier because Deadshot was in there
too so there was like a whole lot of
stuff going on at once it was also the
episode where Oliver revealed himself to
timing for the first time number three
Merlin reveals himself as the dark
Archer for the first time this was also
from that same episode the mid-season
finale in season one not a big surprise
for comic book readers but the way they
filmed it with John Barrowman just
throwing the hood back and showing his
face was so epic during season one I
love the dark Archer scenes I wasn't as
big of a fan of the Malcolm Merlyn
scenes where he was trying to you know
where this facade of a businessman
number two Malcolm Merlyn returns in
season two this was from episode 7 the
state vs Moira queen Merlin had fixed
the trial to get murder off the hook and
he was just beginning to set that fee
applaud into motion I feel like when he
came back for the first time he was
still very much a season one Merlin by
the time he came back in the season two
finale like when he came back from Thea
he was much closer to the Merlin will
see in season three like he was toning
down the crazy just a little bit but
he's still going to be super dark and my
number one Merlin moment the season one
finale fight Oliver in Merlin's final
battle was one of the best action scenes
that year and the fight totally isn't
over remember they didn't cross paths in
season 2 i'm expecting them to pick
things back up wherever they left off
whenever they meet in season 3 i mean at
least at first there's no way that
they're not going to throw down just a
little bit but obviously i'm hoping that
they team up against racial cool I was
actually hoping to get that moment in
the season 2 finale but they might have
just been holding something like that
for season 3 I
feel like making them you know fight
kind of pick back up for season one left
off and they have to grit their teeth
and fight like a big big villain would
be so much more fun let me know that
what is your favorite Malcolm Merlyn
moment of all time and do you think that
he's going to team up with Oliver
against racial goal this season also i'm
working on a flash video for tonight so
i'll post that later but there's some
special Star Wars stuff happening
tomorrow and I have a few special
announcements about stuff that's coming
so it's not happening yet but I'm going
to be doing a charity drive in October
for charity water i'll make a special
video explaining everything real soon
but until then i'm just going to be
dropping notes so that you guys are
loosely aware whatever it's coming up
I've been wanting to do a charity drive
for a while now so it'll just be a good
opportunity for us to turn all this
tv-watching into some actual social good
so right now you can click here to get
that flash video I'll add the annotation
whenever I post it tonight and you can
click here to learn about the arrow
flash crossover this season thank you so
much watching so let's all high five and
we'll meet back up to the flash later
you